non au début de ce journal sur ces
images de neige et divers alors qu'une
vague de froid arrive sur la france et
la région ile de france cette semaine à
saint quentin en yvelines les services
de l'agglomération sont entrés en action
dès ce week-end avec les quelques
flocons à qui sont tombées sur le
territoire
l'objectif sur des sorties lors
d'épisodes neigeux c'est de traiter au
plus près de l'événement donc d'attendre
que l'épisode soit déjà un petit peu
significatif avec de la neige qui tient
au sol alors en fait l'action du sel
permet de diminuer la température de
solidification de l'eau donc ça permet
d'éviter la formation de plaques de
glace lorsque la température descend en
dessous de zéro pendant la nuit et ça
permet effectivement d'accélérer aussi
la fonte de la neige lors du passage des
véhicules sachez d'ailleurs que
l'agglomération met en place un service
d' alerte par sms jusqu'au 31 mars
prochain celui-ci vous permet de
connaître les différentes opérations de
salage et de déneigement plus de
précisions sur
www.esker.fr